let's picture it back end in its
traditional definition is a computer
which is listening for HTTP or websocket
or grpc or any other kind of request
through an open port whether it is 0 or
443 which is accessible over the
Internet so that clients or other front
ends can connect to it send data to it
or receive data depending on the kind of
request and we call it server because it
provides or it serves some kind of
content whether it is static files like
images or JavaScript files or HTML files
or it could be
Json and it also accepts data if this
client sends something now that is a
fair definition of what a back end is
and how it works but I want you to get a
holistic view to actually see the
components physically how they work
behind the scenes so let's go through
this whole flow now I have a backend
server which is deployed in AWS so let's
take that as an
example
demo
users and this is some sample data the
back end is serving so let's do it one
more time and this time open the network
toolbar and if we refresh one more time
let's disable cache so that we get the
appropriate status code all right so
this is the request which starts from a
browser and reaches our server and we
receive this response now we will cover
request and response in a later video
for now let's look at how the whole flow
looks like so let's trace it out let's
Trace how our request starts from our
browser and reaches our server so the
first thing that you can see is the
domain name so if you can see it this is
the domain name Senus doxyz and this is
a subdomain so the first thing that
comes to mind is we should take look at
our DNS server now this is my DNS server
and this part is the important part
where we have defined different types of
Records now DNS itself is a huge topic
so instead of going too deep into that
I'll just give the basics here now to
oversimplify it DNS has different types
of Records you can use a records to
point to a particular IP and you can use
C Name Records to point to a particular
domain name or subdomain right so along
with my other existing domains and
subdomains the thing to focus here is
this part now if you see here we have
two a records and one of them is backend
demo and it is pointing to a particular
IP address and where is this IP address
coming from so this IP address is of an
E2 instance which is in a s now this is
my AWS console let's go to
ec2 and then let's go to
instances and this is the deployed
instance now if you see here this is the
public IP address that that we just saw
in our DNS config so that particular
subdomain which is backend demo points
to this IP address and our request
reaches here to our ec2 instance through
this IP and before it reaches our server
or the particular computer it goes
through a firewall which is the AWS
native firewall the firewall has to
allow some kind of request to go through
now if you look here this is the
security group that is assigned to our
AWS instance uh which basically means
that using this we can specify what are
the ports we want to allow uh what are
the ports that we want to be accessible
over the internet right so you can see
we have allowed three different kinds of
ports and we use this port to log into
our AWS instance to terminals or command
front so that we can do different kinds
of operations and the https and HTTP
ports now this is the important part our
request goes to the domain server which
points to our AWS instance IP and
through the IP it reaches the instance
and before going into the computer it
passes through these firewalls so if we
don't allow these two ports like 443 for
allowing https traffic or 802 allow HTTP
traffic if you don't allow it the AWS
will block it right here and our request
won't be able to reach our server so
this is an important part and finally
after this our request reaches to our
computer now after our request reaches
here into our a instance we are using
something called a reverse proxy which
basically means it is a server which
sits in front of other servers so that
we can manage different types of
redirects or configs from a centralized
space instead of changing the configs in
every single server so for that we are
using enginex and this is how our config
looks like there are a lot of stuff here
but the parts to focus here is we're
using something called sbot to assign
SSL certificates automatically but not
something to worry about in this demo
the parts to focus here is it is
listening for Port 80 in our AWS
instance and it is
redirecting that request to Port 443 so
which is an https request so that part
is managed by sbot and the part that we
have configured is this so what we're
saying is this is my domain name so we
can Define it using the field server
name this is our subdomain back in demo
and whatever request that comes to this
domain so which is already routed by DNS
server so it will reach this instance so
that is not something you have to worry
about and what we are saying is whatever
request that comes to this domain our
engx config will redirect those requests
to our Local Host 3001 which is the port
our server is running on our node server
is running on and this is the final
redirection so if we take a look at our
processes Let's Do
pn2 List we are using pn2 to manage our
processes
so we can see here that we have two
processor running one for front end and
another for back end and this is a node
server so this is the final hop and if
you want we can also check this if you
just do call Local
Host 2001 SL
users and we will get the same response
so from the point of view of this
instance our server our node server is
running in Local Host and we using
engine and domain names to Route
requests to our local server over the
Internet so if we were to summarize our
request starts here in the browser it
goes to our DNS server then that goes to
our AWS servers and it goes through a
firewall and that reaches our AWS
instance right and that request is then
reaches
ngx and that finally forwards that
request to our
Local Host 3001 our final server so it
goes through all these hops until it
finally reaches our server so when we're
developing in our Local Host you can
just open your browser and go to Local
Host 3000 / users and you'll see the
same response and we saw that in our AWS
instance also if you call to our server
we get the same response now you should
have a fair idea of how a request looks
like and how a request travels over the
internet and reaches server but why
exactly do we need these backends I'll
give an example imagine you're scrolling
through your Instagram feed and you come
across your friends posts as usually you
like them you click on the like button
and on the other side your friend gets a
notification that you like their post so
between you clicking on the like button
and your friend getting the notification
what exactly happened now that is where
the concept of backend comes into play
you click on the like button the app
send a request to the server the server
passes that request and sees who is the
user and it finds your name or your ID
or whatever and then it persists and
save that the data the action of you
liking it it has the server has to save
it in some kind of way usually in a
database it saves that information and
then it checks who is the user the user
who's post you like and it finds that
user's ID and it sends a notification it
triggers some kind of action that sends
a notification to that user and the user
gets a notification in their phone so
all these interaction that happened
between you clicking on the like button
and your friend receiving the
notification there has to be some kind
of server a centralized computer that
has to have all kinds of information
about all the users because if you look
at your app it is designed it is
customized according to your needs and
your profile and all the people you
follow right and all the actions that
you can perform on your account
similarly that is the case for your
friend they only receive the
notification that is intended for them
but a server has to have all kinds of
information right all kinds of
information of all kinds of state so it
has to be centralized and from whatever
we have seen till now if you try to
condense down and if you try to strip it
down the responsibility and the use of
backend to a single word it will be this
data right the need to fetch data the
need to receive data and the need to
persist data somewhere and any kind of
actions and every kind of action that
deals with data and if you ask me why
not just do everything on the front end
right since that is also some kind of
device or some kind of computer
depending on what you are using so why
not do it here why not connect to the
database here and why not do every kind
of actions that servers do and since
everything is distributed everywhere
we'll have better performance right
technically and that is an excellent
question so in order to understand that
why can't we use all those
functionalities in front end we have to
see how front ends actually work behind
the scenes now like our earlier backend
demo let's do a demo for how front end
works from end to end this is a nextjs
application that I have deployed in the
same aws2 instance open the network
toolbar again and let's hit the refresh
and what we see here is the first
document that the browser fetches we
look at this it calls this domain name
and if you look at the response it is an
HTML file the browser fetches the HTML
file and all the resources for example
all these JavaScript and all the images
the fonts and the CSS files all of those
different things are fetched in
different different requests after we
have our primary HTML file and in our
record we see that we have an entry for
this subdomain which is front end demo
and it points to this particular IP
address and if you trace that we land
here which is the a E2 instance and we
can see that this is the same public IP
address next as usual the port 443 and
the port 80 has to be allowed for https
and HTTP traffic to get through to our
server and finally the request land here
our ec2 instance and if you look at the
engine config this is what it looks like
again most of the things are the same
same as it was in our backend server we
have the same Serb configs but the thing
that is different is here we are
listening for this domain which is the
front end demo and whatever traffic that
comes to here we are redirected to the
Local Host 3000 instead of redirecting
to 3001 we are redirecting to Port 3000
and finally the request reaches our
frontend nextjs server which serves the
files which is the JS file the CSS file
and the HTML file which are sent over
the network to our browser and after
going through all of that after we
receive our main HTML file what the
browser does is it goes through all
these resources the JavaScript files the
CSS files and the fonts and it fetches
them one by one once it fetches all the
CSS which you can see here it paints our
window that's how we get all these
Styles the background black and these
fonts and these button Styles and once
the browser fetches all the JavaScript
files that's when it hydrates all the
event listeners for buttons and all any
kind of interactions that we have in
this page for example if you click on
this button this is what it happens it
redirects to another page that happened
because the browser fetched all the
JavaScript added all the event listeners
and that's how the button started
working so what do we notice here
whatever front end logic that you have
written whatever the JavaScript that you
have written is all fetched by the
browser from our server and it is
executed by the browser in our machine
in client's machines right so the
browser is our runtime compared to our
traditional backends which we saw
earlier the one in AWS ec2 instance
where we sent a request the server
processed the request and sent us the
result so the actual processing happened
on the server right and it is exactly
the opposite for front end where it
sends us the code but the browser runs
the code whatever logic that is run it
is run by the browser so that is a key
difference to notice here now there are
a couple of issues that we find here
right because browser run times are
often sandbox environments which means
they are isolated from our operating
systems the processes and the file
system everything is an isolated
environment which means the code can
only access limited amount of resources
for example the Dom which is the
document object and browser apis for
example local storage or cookies and
external apis but only if the external
API has the all the required amount of
headers we have not covered course yet
which we will in a future video in much
more depth but you can imagine course as
a policy a security policy of browsers
which restricts JavaScript code to call
external apis which is not the same as
the current domain for example we have
this frontend app in this domain which
is frontend demo
doxyz so we can only call resources or
can only fetch resources and call
external apis which are in the same
domain if we try to call a different
domain then the browser will block the
request because of course policy and
there are ways to get around that which
are through HTTP headers which we will
explore later and if you think about it
all these sandboxing and security
restrictions make sense because
essentially what a browser is doing is
it is fetching code from a remote server
and executing it in the the users
browser and if it's not careful enough
or isolated enough the remote code can
easily access data or files from users's
computer which is not a good thing for
example imagine you go to a website and
you have no idea what is the prent code
of that website and if browsers did not
isolate environments that code can
easily get access to your file system
copy all your files your sensitive
details and send it to their servers
right so that is a very scary idea
that's why browsers have all these
security policies now coming back to our
original question why can't we write
backend logic in front end so the first
thing obviously is security
reasons security
reasons because the security policies of
browsers are so restrictive and often
times a back needs to access underlying
file system whether it's to write to a
log file or access environment variables
and browsers won't allow that that is a
huge restrict
for a backend server the second thing is
you cannot call external apis whenever
you want unless that API has all the
appropriate cor headers and since we
don't have control over all the external
apis this is also a big deal breaker
because backend servers often need to
connect to other servers and fetch data
from multiple places so we cannot have
this restriction now the third thing is
databases
now the server runtime has access to all
Native database drivers for example PG
for postgis and mongodb and that allows
it to communicate efficiently with
databases these drivers are written to
work in environments that can handle
socket connections handle binary data
and maintain persistent connections
things that browsers cannot do and we
will explore later how backend servers
communicated with databases but to
simplify it backend servers maintain a
list of connection
uh which is often called a connection
pool to our database server so that it
does not have to create and Destroy
connections again and again because
backend servers receive thousands and
thousands of requests in seconds and if
they do the connecting and destroying
logic with each request the data server
is going to get overwhelmed and it
cannot handle that load so drivers are
written in a way that can maintain a
list of connections and browsers are not
designed to maintain persistent
connections to databases and even if
they were each user would need to open
their own delete connection to the
database overwhelming the database
server with too many connections there
is also no easy way to manage connection
pooling or efficient query execution
from the browser environments now the
last thing
is computing
power front end
applications as we use them are
everywhere it could be a smartphone it
could be be a desktop it could be a
laptop and any kind of environments that
we can imagine even a computer which has
a 256 mbf RAM and with a single core
processor and the user might not have
enough computing power to perform some
heavy business logic and things will
start to lag and sometimes break because
of the load so for that reason if it's a
centralized backend server which serves
and CS to a large number of clients we
can easily increase its memory and and
CPU whenever we want and we can easily
deal with the load we can continue this
list as long as we want but this should
give you a fair idea that keeping
backend logic in front end is not a good
idea uh that is assuming if we can do it
in the first place great now we have
seen what a backend is why do we need it
and how does it work on a very high
level now this is a very good place to
be in before we start our journey of
learning backend engineering now let's
explore what are these principles and
why we should learn in this particular
way